welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Rick and Morty actually
[ __ ] did it
they had a time-travel episode and not a
characters can see their futures and
that's time travel in a metaphorical
sense let's tempt fate and call it time
travel in our after-show episode and
give the [ __ ] Rick and Morty
commenters more cardio than they've ever
had in their lives as they actually in
all caps put actual legit time travel
with a planet of snakes who have knotted
themselves into a terminator time loop
scenario that Rick has to untangle as
Rick says this episode so that's about
as much curvature as you're gonna get
from a time travel story Eddie's right
the term curvature is meta-commentary by
the Rick and Morty writing staff
referring to how they challenge
themselves to curb their stories with
wild unpredictable arts as opposed to
you know simple linear stories that most
other TV shows settle for and this Rick
and Morty version of time-travel is not
the linear plot hole filled one that
most time-travel fiction is but an
insanely dense curved one that both
blows out its concept to its furthest
logical conclusions and then neatly
loops back on itself with a literal
punchline but enough fellating the
writing let's slow down the breakneck
pace of this episode - Rick's plane how
exactly the time travel works in Rick
and Morty Season 4 episode 5 rattle star
eclectic ax so famously Rick and Morty
has steered away from time travel as a
story concept considering it an overdone
trope in sci-fi still time travel does
exist in this universe and the pilot
episode Rick jumps ahead to a more
medically advanced future and of course
Rick's time travel stuff box has rested
in the garage every episode forever
untouched but why do time travel now
well apparently there is something else
Dan Harmon hates nearly as much as time
travel snakes snakes snakes they suck
they're not supposed to have space
programs do there that's was to live and
dominate a planet their gross little
holdovers from
from when we evolved from worms if we're
gonna make a whole snake society and go
down this dumb loophole and and do all
this dumb stuff that the biggest dumb
leap we could do is time travel so let's
deep down this snake hole to see how
deep it goes because it's pretty damn
impressive how far the writers will go
to prove how dumb something is so Morty
swaps in an earth snake slippy to
replace the snake astronaut II killed
but that results in snake scientists
in the language barrier between snakes
that caused their race conflicts
allowing them to evolve technologically
beyond the point that they should have
this evolution leads to a terminator
time travel assassin scenario morty gets
targeted by a cyborg snake of serpent
core a hive mind kind of like Skynet but
then you get saved by a shotgun toting
snake and then they also get protection
from another t800 style protector at the
future snake resistance made to try to
look human and Beth crushes it and all
this goes down while in the background
the time-travel stuff box is literally
tipped over spilling out everywhere
there are actually a ton of animation
details in this episode that I will
reveal shot by shot in my breakdown of
the episode coming next on the channel
but moving on there's a Sarah Connor
style monologue explaining in the future
post-apocalyptic history of the snakes
17 billion snake lives ended on June
21st 2026 the survivors lived only to
face a new nightmare
the war between
in the end snake overcame the snow
because of what we couldn't predict that
an alien distance star save us so Rick
and Morty commando into the snake planet
to try to undo this time travel and
already we see the overcomplicated
nonsensical wrinkles of it this is a
multi twist Sarah Connor set up kind of
like Terminator Genisys if you're one of
you who watch that movie snake cyborgs
once to kill slippy and her John Connor
a baby's future snake robot says to stop
but then a knife-wielding Molina snakes
wants to kill and then a future snake
wants to protect this over complicated
structure gets compounded when Rick
realizes he has to invent snake time
travel for them leading to future
versions of Rick and Morty showing up
with snake costumes and a black eye and
time-travel devices so they go to snake
MIT 1985 which is the same origin year
up Back to the Future there's actually a
snake Back to the Future poster in that
lab to leave them with a sports Almanac
type book to incept time travel among
the snakes so unlike most time-travel
fiction in which the solution is to go
back and prevent time travel from being
invented Rick solution is more time
travel because as we've seen in series
like The Terminator once time travel
gets introduced in fictional universes
it's a can of worms in which every
attempt to stamp out time travel just
gets stupidly prevented by a
hypothetical future who once time-travel
so Rick just fast track's this process
he gives them too much time travel so
that the snakes will inevitably overdo
it we're removing ourselves from this
sloppy fucked-up story and letting snake
time travel eat its own tail it's such a
great line because like a snake eating
its own tail it connects the suckiness
of one's lucky thing with a sucky nough
some another sucky thing time travel
equals snakes so the time travel logic
applies to the two most common linchpin
historical developments at time
travelers would change the assassination
of Abraham Lincoln and the rise of
Hitler so the 80 snake saves Lincoln but
when he returns his snake for instinct
Isles and he realized this snake Lincoln
was a fascist which is a great callback
to the fascist dimensions of the season
premiere episode and then the missions
to assassinate snake Hitler escalate
into a freaking bloody
balle we just gotta wait for him to blow
by a cop in the intervene back to the
first snake's ever use technology Oh
you a smart snake huh you using tools
now huh
those toons gonna turn into you
manipulating a fabrica stick so all the
snakes fade from existence literally
eating their own tails in the episode
returns Morty and Rick to their future
selves so they have to complete the
snake costumes and time-travel devices
to give it to their past selves and we
finally learned how Morty got his black
eye I feel like we're forgetting
something oh yeah thanks for reminding
me Morty
next time stay in the car this episode
closes the loop of its own time travel
so that it never needs to be used again
though technically it can since Rick
still has those devices but obviously he
doesn't want to ever use them so back in
the box they will probably go
impressively one of the most complex
time travel plots we've ever seen
unfolds and I counted this in just six
minutes and 33 seconds of runtime of the
episode so if you feel betrayed that
Rick and Morty did a time-travel episode
something they promised they would never
do they did essentially pull what is the
equivalent of a double McTwist 1260 of
time-travel stories in a fraction of the
time of most other time-travel fiction
and Rick and Morty committing to a good
time travel episode was actually
predicted in the past episode of this
show you know what I would think would
be very interesting is this like maybe
the like final 70th episode yeah they
maybe did a time travel finally they
yeah and it almost did a way to like
alright now we're gonna do the really
cool thing that we shouldn't have ever
done right yeah we did agree to do it so
it seems like it would be a good
challenge to make that final yeah I feel
like you guys haven't like smart enough
science fiction people in the room that
you could actually do a time travel
story that is both like logical and
makes sense but it's also like
entertaining and so to run a victory lap
on that prediction we had brought back
writer and comedian Abed Gaither and
other special guests to dive deeper into
the time-travel of this historic episode
after a quick message from our sponsors
why do people still go to the post
office especially during the holidays
when everyone is trying to send gift
cards and cards to loved ones or
fruitcakes to unloved ones anything you
can do at the post office
you can do it stamps.com stamps comm
eliminates trips to the post office and
saves you money with disk
that you can't get at the post office
here at new rockstars we've been using
stamps calm to ship rewards to our
patreon patrons it's been really really
helpful a big time-saver and if you're a
patron keep an eye out for that hot hot
merch blazing up your mailboxes
stamps.com brings all the services of
the US Postal Service right to your
computer whether you're a small office
sending invoices and online sellers
shipping out products or even a
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
not to mention it's a fraction of the
cost of expensive postage meters
stamps.com is a no-brainer saving you
time and money
it's no wonder 700 thousand small
businesses already use stamps calm don't
spend a minute of your holiday season at
the post office this year sign up for
stamps calm instead there's no risk with
my promo code are explained you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage in a digital
scale just go to stamps calm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Rick's plane that
is stamps comm inter explained stamps
calm never go to the post office again
support for explained also comes from
manscaped
the best and men's below-the-belt
grooming manscaped offers precision
engineered tools for your family jewels
time-traveling snakes are the least of
your worries what about a snake with fur
that's too long and gets caught in your
zipper it's time to gear up to get
yourself the gift of Shaving this
holiday season I'm talking about the
manscaped perfect package 2.0 holiday
sweaters might be itchy and furry but
you don't need to be
that's why manscaped has redesigned the
electric trimmer their lawnmower 2.0 has
proprietary skin safe technology so this
trimmer will not Nick or snag your nuts
it's also waterproof so you can use it
in shower
the lawnmower 2.0 comes inside their
perfect package 2.0 which makes the
perfect gift this holiday season it's
literally everything you need to keep
trimmed cut free smelling ice down there
and everything you need in life
the manscaped perfect package 2.0
includes the crop preserver and crop
Reviver to keep your balls from sweating
smelling and sticking these products
smell good they're manly scent is
attractive and will help set the mood if
you know what I mean baby it's gonna be
real cold outside get 20% off and free
shipping with the code ricks plain dat
manscape calm that's 20% off with free
shipping a manscape calm when he used to
code were explained alright welcome back
and here to talk with us about this
Rick and Morty are some very special
guests are happy to have on the show
first time on the rocks Jessica Chobot
thank you so much for coming on my
pleasure hopefully I have something
worthwhile to contribute or two out of
the loop a little bit Oh No well you'll
be in the loop now especially with our
other guests here coming back to the
show Abed gate hello thank you so much
for coming on man thanks for having me
back
well let's talk about this guys because
this is a historic moment Rick and Morty
finally did a time-travel episode
something they promised they would never
do
despite time-travel existing in the
universe and I mean they did kind of
hint at it in the first episode of the
series but they finally did a whole time
travel episode so what do we think was
the straw that broke the camel's back
with the room was it just a hatred of
snakes or was it like no it's it's
finally time to to address this I think
the second thing yeah like I think maybe
they just got over they're sort of like
all right who cares
yeah science fiction we might as well
yeah you know cuz I think it's it's a
kind of good idea to use time travel in
this situation yeah what was the what
was always the issue with doing it
before like what was the part what was
the problem just like it was done to
death that's a everybody does people
groan when there's like I groaned an EDD
game I was like oh God you know cuz I
was like that annoys me because but in
this situation with the snakes I really
thought it was kind of cool yeah yeah
cuz I always I always liked the fact
that they attacked ropes and so if this
for them was a trope there's so many
seasons in already and so confident with
their footing at this point that it
makes sense to do it now because it's
just just another trope that they're
hitting you're right yeah that's the
thing like this is a show that's a
parody so in a sense you have to make
fun of time travel yeah that's good so
and and like I said any game I was like
well that's a movie that doesn't mean
time-travel mm-hm you know we got so
much stuff already yeah but with Rick
and Morty like they like to go to every
sci-fi trope and kind of do their tape
yes I think that it was inevitable yeah
like famous hanging references to grab
the it's interesting that like they they
finally did it and they did it justice I
feel like it was they were smarter about
the way they structured their time
travel than like most other time trap
plats I've seen which are pretty linear
like Rick has that line that's the most
curvature you'll see with the time yeah
yeah and in a way they're getting back
to their roots too because Rick and
Morty and the channel 101 shorts were
like based on it really crude doc and
Marty x-rated short ed Justin roiland
did and they they're able to go back
with kind of a Back to the Future style
like time-travel plot so it feels like a
homecoming in a way yeah I thought they
rode the line for this really well where
they made reference obviously like you
said to Back to the Future
Terminator they did justice with all the
things that they were calling back to
and everything that we're familiar with
from a pop-culture standpoint but also
and but also giving us a plot that was
convoluted enough that you're like yep
time-travel but not so much that you
couldn't figure out why it was happening
you know like they were just really rode
that because either way if you start
tipping one way or the other either
becomes too boring because it's too
obvious or then it becomes so convoluted
that you're completely lost yeah and so
they just yeah I thought they did a good
job kind of riding right down the middle
yeah it was earned it was like they they
didn't need time time we were just
exploring the snake world but like it
was a natural consequence of letting the
snake world continue involved of course
they would invent time travel and abuse
it so quickly I love this I'm a big fan
of like Buster Keaton two chaplains so I
love that silent just with me I sit with
this like that was great because it's
telling a story without words to me is
very it takes a lot of skill yeah and it
was a very visual fun section of the
episode kind of my favorite yeah it's so
different than anything you see today
which is too wordy yeah nah man you were
saying how like the it takes such a long
time to actually animate these things
and there's so much detail in that snake
world like everything was snake
equivalent like the columns were
serpentine and the way they were
designed so like clearly they had to put
a lot of love and crafts and it just
doing the visual storytelling of this
episode maybe by doing that it it set
the stage to have a very wordy over
complicated time-travel plot in the last
like six minutes of you yeah it was
balanced yeah pretty well
because for a time travel episode like
you were saying like you have to kind of
make it either convoluted or very simple
so I liked that it got really
complicated yeah cuz also episode you
can watch again yeah and then find
little things you missed now that is
interesting that by having a lack of by
having only snake language and so
therefore kind of a silent movie we were
able to kind of get away with more of
the weird side time travel element and
not get too confusing because if the
snakes could actually talk and they
could understand that would have been so
overwhelming right there's a movie I
don't know I can't remember now but
whenever there's like people talking to
their language they didn't have
subtitles yeah and I thought that was
amazing horses did that in some scene
exactly subtitle because you have to
read body language and yeah that's way
more interesting way to tell a story
than with words yes so like to me that
was kind of incredible yeah and that's
where I give my head off to I don't have
a had but this episode yeah and and the
writers reading snake body they were it
was really clever like they would use
the ends of the tales as like hands and
they could like there was a moment where
the scientist snake held his briefcase
over his head to shield him from the
rain this is troupe things yeah I I
think the writers trusted us to be able
to follow it when there's no words and
when there's too much words yeah to like
the twist were in Sangamon wasn't
interesting is to go back and watch it
again and pay attention if different
types of snakes had different social
rankings oh sure in their society like
we're all the rattlesnakes the soldiers
because one of them that I think I saw a
rattlesnake punching somebody that's
regular to us
yeah I wonder if going back but it was
you know so quick that I wasn't I didn't
at the time but I wonder if social
stratification is based on what oh yeah
types of snakes they are I don't know
why did this but the two ends of the
snake is the Offutt of the room the
snake sex right yeah like well that was
cuz like I think you said that's how
snakes have said they wrap around you
wrapped around themselves around I mean
I was educated today yes so that's so I
like to know how snakes have sex so when
I go nature hunting like hey I know how
it goes down yeah and you'll notice
slowly back away from them when you see
that sit down start watch I don't think
that I want to see snakes have sex I'm
just like well now I'm educated so I
know when to leave the premises yeah
Morty did draw the marker on slippy it
was almost like a star bellied sneetches
kind of thing yeah there was definitely
some social caste system to the snakes I
got a I got a go look at this at their
time so what I've liked about the season
is each episode seems like it starts
from a place of a gripe like that either
Dan Harmon or one of the writers have
like there was a past episode about
heist movies and how annoying heist
plots are there's an episode about how
they want to have their own private
toilet and and and how that turns into
this big plot there's never said about
how like magic is annoying and because
it's unexplained in this episode was
about like kind of like how snakes are
just freakin annoying and they're able
to create a time-travel plot that
thematically and visually comes back to
this idea of snakes eating their own
tail and that's what time-travel grows
yeah thank you yeah I only know that
term cuz of red dwarf yeah I think I
know that term cuz of Skyrim it's a
symbol very bright it's just from
something I've seen yeah is it not a
Harry Potter anything what magical they
always reference it what I believe but
do snakes ever actually eat their own
tails like I feel like they're smart
enough that's a lot of these I see my
cat going after its tail a lot but I
don't know okay would definitely eat the
tail cats do we think there's uh so this
was a pretty big turning point to have a
time travel episode but to me it seems
like this is self-contained like I don't
imagine them doing another time travel
episode in the future but could you see
them and do you want them to pursue
other angles a time travel like this is
a close
Loup Terminator style time travel would
could you see like another you know all
three time line time travel or
slaughterhouse-five style time travel oh
that's one body that would be
interesting I'd like to see a primer one
that's very technical sure
yeah but I mean time travel is just it
is so done to death yeah that I hope
they never do it again
until maybe the 70th episode yeah yeah
because then it's like maybe do one
where they go back to the pilot yeah
yeah
I forget what show did that but I mean
endgame kind of did that by going back
to past movies I feel like they look so
a from Back to the Future too they did
they did and then they talked about how
they weren't doing Back to the Future 2
but then they basically just effects but
not as well to do it I don't know I felt
like sac 2 of endgame I wish that was
the whole movie I'm just like every
single have Lewis go there and like
narrate what they're doing like I feel
like there's so much more cashing in to
do but then they they just kind of moved
away from it just so they could have a
big battlefront where they just wanted
to kind of quickly get through the film
yeah so I feel like they just threw that
in there like it didn't feel natural to
me right yeah yeah I would have to agree
with you unless unless wait until it's
like the souvaine
70th episode and even then have it a
different approach to time-travel but
you know I feel totally content with
this episode and what they did with it
yeah I got I was entertained the whole
time so I'm good I agree I think if
you're gonna do time travel do it that
way yeah like you said like make it kind
of convoluted and confusing and so I
have to watch it again because most of
the time time travel it shouldn't be
easy to understand yeah and what was
great about it is they they snuck it on
us right like the episodes title was
rattle star eclectic and I'm thinking
like a Battlestar Galactica we're
getting Cylons we're gonna have like
some kind of weird time setting twist
which is like the final episode or
there's some kind of religious overtones
away battle started but it was none of
that it was there's no time travel in
Battlestar Galactica it was clear they
just titled it that episode so that they
could in the third act of this episode
subtly introduced I'm sure well they
they didn't do time travel but they did
remember they jumped ahead six months
they did it's a way of time travel it's
like putting yeah yeah it's pretty
complete versus right but I mean yeah
that's not the same yeah you know I
guess time travel is going back right
yeah or like alternate timeline
persistent yeah so I kind of love that I
don't I'm glad that they didn't come out
and say
we're doing our time travel episode
because that would have built up
expectations way too right right right
right well and also they're not gonna do
that just because then you're gonna get
some backlash right you get people crazy
like we all know these fans are out of
their minds yeah so they're gonna be
like what you guys said you never do
time travel like they're gonna go nuts
so it's like it's better to do it this
way and to kind of like carry you along
and surprise you in a sort of like fun
way all right
the times they are a-changin well that's
a great place to snake ate its own tail
finally the it's been so great chatting
with you guys do you have any things
that you're working on that you want to
share well I have a lot of stuff that
I'm working on that I can't share but
look for it next year hopefully sooner
rather than later I think around
February yeah based on what I know about
the Edit and then I'm actually going to
be launching a paranormal podcast with a
friend of mine named Bowser over here at
Star burns very excited yeah so probably
not until you know it's Christmas break
very very soon or holiday break for
others and it's like we know that it is
everybody's cashed out already and so
we're not even gonna try and launch
anything until after everybody's back
from the holiday vacations okay well
great but yes we're definitely doing it
well we look forward to that thanks
Inaba do you have lots of secret
projects with that well I ain't never
did the weird thing is I think I can
announce one of them in February okay
but the other one I just started so I
don't know yet what it's gonna be but it
is like an animated things so that's
gonna be fun
so yeah watch for that if you follow me
on Twitter and Instagram I'll probably
you were able to find out when I can't
announce it well Abed gave Jessica
Chobot thank you so much for coming on
this show it's been a delight having you
here to talk about this monumental
episode of Rick and Morty be sure to
follow us at new rock stars and
subscribe to a rich plain podcast feed
because we will be doing after shows for
right yeah for the rest of the season
whenever it comes right in 2020 think
January we'll see I can follow me a TA
boss and thank you and keep an eye out
for our breakdown of all the animation
jokes oh you missed this episode we'll
close out this episode of explain with
our favorite line of the episode come on
I can recognize the sound of a seagull
can you recognize the sound of a man's
pants filling up with rain I hope to one
day
[Music]